kommunale penner
ich habe hier gerade bei facebook was
unglaubliches gelesen
keine ahnung ob das stimmt aber erst mal
teil peter altmaier paniert bio
deutschen und frisst ihn mit mayonnaise
was ist das für ein land altmaier das
schwein dafür ist facebook erfunden
worden
wir wollen ein zustand der dauer
erregung wut angst und zwischendurch mal
ein bild von [ __ ] den ameisenbären
dann aber auch wieder gut ameisenbären
chance die von facebook liegt von hass
wie so ein alter dank parasit und stadt
etwas daran zu ändern
machen sie jetzt zum ersten mal werbung
in deutschland mit ekelhafter pseudo
selbstkritik und solchen spots diese
welle an informationen die man über
facebook bekommt hat in den meisten
fällen keine substanz die ganze
nachrichten also mehr hat das jetzt dein
leben bereichert 0 machen facebook zu
meinem facebook das ist zu viel von dem
geld das diese spots kosten könntet ihr
auch mal ein paar leute einstellen und
endlich die ganzen holocaust leuten auf
facebook sperren und wenn schon werbung
dann wenigstens ehrlich
also echt abstoßend nur für mich diesen
wahnsinnig aggressiven ton im netz ist
total schade dass man da ständig
angepöbelt wird von irgendwelchen
kriminellen juden und kümmel töten ist
schon ganz gut dass der führer dieses
internet nicht mehr erleben muss
facebook gucke ich nie das kommt immer
so spät sagen deutsche politiker es muss
endlich mal was passieren
wegen dem ganzen hass auf facebook
nichts passiert das einzige was immer
gesperrt wird sie nach wie vor tippen
dafür habe ich
mach facebook doch einfach mal aus da
wird man nämlich blöd von
[Applaus]